- C'est un logement
On va faire de petites choses
pour s'assurer, comme boucher
les trous.
- Propriétaire de cet immeuble
depuis une dizaine d'années,man.
- Ici on va devoir l'ajustercom.
- Quand son homme à tout faire
a pris sa retraite, le prix
avait explosé. Trouver un
contracteur l'a désillusionnée.
VÉRONIQUE ST-ONGE, propriétaire
de me faire avoir.ire avoir.ire,
on ne sait jamais comment
ils font, on ne sait pas quand
nt qu'à payer quelqu'un
que je ne connais pas, qui fait
s qui ne sont pas tant
difficiles à mon avis, bien,
je vais les faire moi-même.
- Pourtant, elle partait
de loin. Manier la perceuse
Elle s'est donc tournée vers
des cours de rénovr
apprendre les petits travaux,
et réaliser de grosses
- Écoute, je pense qu'on en
aurait eu au moins pour 2000 $,.
- Je vais le mesurer et je v
- OK.
- Stéphanie Lévesq
lancée dans les ateliers
de rénovations il y a
plus d'uheuresheuresheuresheures
coûte entre 65 et 100 $.
La demande pour ses formations a
bondi d'environ 25 %
STÉPHANIE LÉVESQUE, ébéniste,
atelier Stéphanie
- La pénurie de main-d'oeuvre,
ça se ressent partout
et ça se ressent ée de
la construction; et l'explosion
des coû
combines, là, ont fait en sorte
que les gens voulaient se
réapproprier, en fait, leur
intérieur.
- Les dépenses en rénovation
ets au Quéets au Quéets au Quée.
Et elles devraient se chiffrer à
ards de dollars en 2022.
- Donc, même choranc.
(coup de marteau)
- On filme une cap
franc. Les cours de Stéphanie,
forts de leur popu
empruntent le virage web...
un outillage aussi qui est un
peu dangereux dans le sens où
la lame tourne vers soi.is en le
aux quatre coins du Québec.
Le projeenariat
avec l'entreprise Les filles
de la construction, est destiné
éotypes fééotypes fééotypes féé,
en matière de rénovations.
MARIE-FRANCE CÔTÉ NOLET, fond.,
onstruction
- On a l'impression
que c'est une affaire de gars.
s petites filles ou
comme des petites madames dansa,
honnêtement, super, t'sais, ...
genre dévalorisant et ça nousjut
puis qu'on n'est pas capables.-,
les travaux manuels sont-ils
vraiment pour tout le monde?
que, oui, c'est accessible
à tout le monde, mais, non,
ce n'est pas tout le monde
qui aime ça.- Oui. Pour vrai, j!
- Si Véronique a joint l'utileàs
lui permettront à l'avenir
de mieux négocier avec
- Parce que je vais savoir
de quoi je parle. Je vais
être capable de challenger
la personne. Ça
- Des éc
lui permettront de réaliser,
elle-même, de plus grands
projets.
Radio-Canada, Mon